[Música]
no son ustedes los que me eligieron
hace
[Música]
algunos años de haber sido hace unos
tres años más o menos
mi sobrina alina me dice un día
oye tío tú no tienes otra ropa
y le digo porque allí no te gusta mi
ropa y ese motivo está bien pero sería
chévere verte vestido de una manera
diferente alguna vez
y una manera muy similar la hija de una
amiga
le pregunta a ella le dice
mama
el padre alberto cuando estaba chiquito
fue a un colegio como para padres oa un
colegio normal
y la respuesta es que fue un colegio
normal en este colegio de grado en el
año 95
y contra todos los planes y pronósticos
terminen siendo cura
bueno eso fue acá en el colegio cuando
estábamos en sexto cuando llegué a vivir
acá después de haber estado en bogotá
puedo decirles que en este colegio y tal
vez de los años más felices que viven mi
vida de sexto a once
primero el año duro porque llegó el rolo
que había que hacerle el hoy llamado
bullying antes montársela
pero después fue de verdad una
experiencia genial una experiencia por
la cual yo le doy muchas gracias a dios
de todo lo que yo puedo vivir en este
colegio
cuanto nos reímos cuánto
nos pegamos nos peleamos jugamos hicimos
mil cosas que realmente hizo que
con estos 12 personajes junto conmigo
esto fue en la fiesta de 15 de mi
hermana sé que algunas por aquí
estuvieron en esa fiesta memorable
vivimos años muy chéveres de verdad muy
muy chéveres y yo puedo decir que junto
a estos personajes aprendí que era la
amistad
tanto que cuando yo fui llegando al
final del colegio estaba tan seguro de
mí mismo y de los amigos que tenía de lo
que iba a lograr en mi vida que
lo voy a hacer bien tengo buenos amigos
tengo una muy buena familia
tenía una novia linda chévere
y dije bueno y ahora qué hago qué tengo
que hacer para seguir adelante con esto
que ya como que es una crónica de algo
que va a terminar bien
y entonces dije pues tengo que buscar
algo para estudiar que garantice que
pueda tener los recursos que necesito
para seguir adelante con esto y en ese
último año de colegio decidí que iba a
estudiar la economía entré a la
universidad en bogotá me fui a estudiar
allá y me fui con esta idea de el éxito
de que tenía que ser una persona exitosa
no sé si reconocida pero exitosa que
pudiese hacer lo que yo quería
tener esta familia soñada no sé viajar
tener un carro chévere n cosas de lo que
pensaba que era la vida
y resulta que los primeros dos años de
universidad se me fueron entre
responder con lo que tenía que hacer
creo que siempre he sido más o menos
responsable y rumbear y salir y poco a
poco mi vida se fue convirtiendo en ve y
que vamos a hacer el viernes con quién
vamos a salir para donde nos vamos
y poco a poco eso como que al principio
era muy atractivo
como que fue perdiendo sentido
y sin darme cuenta en un momento me
estaba empezando a sentir solo
que tengo que contar una cosa y es que
hubo una semana santa que no fue tan
santa en el 97
y después de esa semana santa me acuerdo
que estuvimos en un sitio con amigos y
todo y cuando llegamos a bogotá un
domingo de resurrección que no tienen ni
idea que sería eso
le digo a este amigo le digo sea que me
acompañas a confesarme
y este man de mira como este mal se
volvió loco
yo hoy me confieso con el cura
y sinceramente no significó mucho
simplemente estaba decirle a alguien que
me está haciendo mal que había algo que
no estaba bien en mi vida pero no es que
ese día yo empecé a ir a misa barbas y
no pasó nada simplemente fui una rodilla
y le dije unas cosas y seguí adelante
pasa mes y medio y estamos estudiando al
terminar cuarto semestre un examen de
probabilidad
esta aburridísimo estudiando yo tenía un
par de amigas con las que estudiaba y
ellas dos empiezan a contar que ha
venido un sitio donde supuestamente se
aparece a la virgen
y una de ellas era muy creyente la otra
más bien no creyente y la no creyente
empieza a decir mira alberto ahí pasa
algo raro yo no puedo explicar lo que
pasó y esta niña estaba cambiada y medio
radiante
y hubo algo que en ese momento como que
tuve claro
ahí pasa algo realmente algo dice la
virgen o algo le quiere decir dios a
estas personas o nos quiere decir dios a
nosotros
y sin darle muchas vueltas yo tuve ese
día una gran certeza
es que dios nos habla a nosotros los
hombres
y yo tal vez me pregunte no será que
esté vacío que yo estoy sintiendo es
porque mi vida realmente tengo todo
y lo único que no tenía en ese momento
era adiós
y una intuición muy grande que me dijo
lo que a ti te hace falta es dios
termino ese día y esa semana yo llamé a
la amiga creyente y le digo oye será que
el domingo puedo ir contigo a misa me
dice sí claro entonces como voy a misa
la iglesia estaba repleta y por primera
vez en mi vida y tenía 20 años
le puse atención a lo que el cura decía
por eso es que hoy en día cuando no me
ponen atención a veces como tengo que
trabajar mucho con niños o con
adolescentes digo
nunca le ha puesto atención a un cura
nunca había terminado la misa y cuando
me preguntaban que dijo tony idea
y esta vez era como si estuviese yo solo
en esa iglesia y este señor me estuviera
hablando a mí
y cristo me estoy hablando a mí
y esto fue muy fuerte
y como que yo dije en verdad dios le
habla a uno
entonces de ahí fue una segunda vez a
misa y una tercera vez a misa y tuve una
experiencia similar
y esto ya como que ya no empezó a
parecer como tan chévere sino como será
que a mí me lavaron el cerebro y yo no
me di cuenta yo me estoy metiendo una
cosa rara y esto que yo estoy sintiendo
nunca lo haya sentido
en verdad que me está pasando
esto era ya terminando el semestre y
como buen caleño en bogotá quería
venirme de una para cali y en ese
momento
pues yo dije no yo tengo que alguien me
tiene que ayudar a saber qué es lo que
me está pasando con esto yo tengo un par
de primos curas que son primos de mi
papá uno de ellos dos años atrás me da
entrega una tarjeta de él diciendo me
mira como estás viendo en bogotá aquí
está mi tarjeta por si alguna vez me
necesitas y yo llegué que hoy la
televisión a trata de un cura y
y cuando la necesite me tocó llaman las
que están ahí papá para que mira el
teléfono bueno lo llamo y él me dice
necesitas hablar conmigo 20 y me voy
ahora a donde él
les cuento lo que me estaba pasando me
confieso y al final él me dice mira
alberto yo creo que dios te está
llamando no sé a qué pero yo creo que
ello se está llamando y ponla atención a
esto y sigue adelante si quiere yo te
voy a acompañando y te voy a ayudando a
que a que puedas entender un poco esto
que te está pasando entonces ahí
empezaron a venir mil preguntas muchas
preguntas que me hacía todo el tiempo
sobre dios sobre mi vida que iba a pasar
bueno mil cosas pero en ese momento me
vine a cali en las vacaciones eso es el
90 en el 97 y las vacaciones fueron
común y corriente
pues deporte estar con los amigos nos
íbamos a la finca de alguno rumbear y
así se nos pasaron las vacaciones pero
en ese momento ya hacía algo diferente y
era que yo era el raro que iba a misa
los domingos
yo vivía abajo en la iglesia de santa
teresita y me acuerdo que nunca pisé la
iglesia viviendo abajo de las escaleras
de santa teresita
y empecé a ir a misa
y podía hacer que salir a rumbear y
llegar a tardísimo y decía que tengo que
leerme un pedacito de la biblia y tengo
que rezar algo porque me comprometí a
hacer esto
y así hacía
entonces esas vacaciones como que me
resolvieron la vida yo dije tengo mi
vida como siempre he estado ahora tengo
a dios ya el match es perfecto
y resulta que me regreso a bogotá y al
poco tiempo vuelve y me empiezo a sentir
muy mal
por diferentes razones terminó yendo
donde un sacerdote que decían que era un
buen confesor y voy me confieso con él
le digo un par de cosas y él me dice
usted quiere unos consejitos de vida o
quiere confesarse y yo le digo yo me
quiero confesar pero ayúdeme se me puede
hacer preguntas hablamos largo y al
final él me dice mire yo veo en nuestro
un problema
usted está tratando de unir dos vías que
son bien diferentes la vía del mundo y
la vida de dios
en mi opinión yo le digo escoja no trate
de hacer las dos cosas al mismo tiempo
porque se va a hacer daño a usted miedo
y va a terminar siendo incoherente y
falso
mi hijo si usted escoge la vida del
mundo
probablemente sea una persona feliz
exitosa y bien y siga adelante
pero si usted reconoce que tal vez no lo
esté llamando
y usted quiere optar por el camino de
dios tómese en serio
y le aseguro que ese camino va a ser
difícil pero usted va a ser muy feliz
hágalo
y yo salí ahí
este señor me mandó a rezar al santísimo
primo de la iglesia digo quién será el
santísimo tiene ni la menor idea de
quién era el santísimo nadie me ha
explicado y yo le rezo a lo que yo creía
que eres santísimo y yo me acuerdo que
ese día le dije
dios yo quiero tomarme este camino en
serio
y ahí viene un tiempo en el cual empiezo
a reunirme con otros amigos y nos
reuníamos los jueves a rezar
por otro lado trato de explicarle a mis
amigos de siempre veo a mi hermana en
que me estaba metiendo y entre más se
trataba de contar a alguien me miraban
como este man si está muy loco este man
está muy muy mal
entonces yo dije ya no le digo a nadie y
sigo adelante y yo creo que al principio
y mi familia mis amigos empezaron a como
a tratar de decir que no siguiera en
esto hasta que hoy en día sé que entre
ellos decían no saben mejor no le
digamos nada porque entre más le digan
peor más se le va a meter a esa idea
rara en la cabeza entonces qué monos
callados que eso sería olvidar
y resulta que no se me olvidó
esta foto que está acá
como el resultado de una actividad que
sucedió el 7 de diciembre
con estos amigos que nos reuníamos
dijimos bueno esto no se trata solamente
de rezar tenemos que hacer algo por los
demás entonces porque nos conseguimos
una plata y nos vamos a llevarle pollos
a la gente que vive en la calle
nos armamos unas 300 o 400 bolsitas de
dos presas de pollo dos papas una
cocacola nos reunimos un día como a las
diez de la noche en bogotá y nos fuimos
por toda la caracas hasta la calle del
cartucho estuvimos abajo de la de la
universidad de los andes en
en el parque los periodistas
y ese día yo regrese a mi casa a las 3
de la mañana
con el corazón realmente muy conmovido
por cosas como la siguiente
yo me bajo en un momento en la calle a
levantar a un señor que estaba tirado en
el piso durmiendo con un perro al lado
se levanta dejamos el pollo él abre la
bolsa y la deja abierta
y yo le pregunto el señor pero por qué
no se lo come todavía está caliente
y si no es que yo hace tantos años que
como de la basura y como frío que me
hace daño comer caliente
yo me acuerdo de haber llegado a mi casa
y estar frente al espejo en el baño
recordando todo esto
y me dije no no puede ser que haya gente
tan necesitada en la vida sido tan
afortunada
y ese día yo le dije adiós yo quiero
dedicar mi vida a servir a los demás
esa
certeza esa luz que tuve ese día
es lo que hoy yo vengo a compartirles
hoy yo tengo que decir qué
han pasado ya 18 años desde que viven en
una comunidad religiosa en la comunidad
elite
han pasado 21 años desde esta historia
que les cuento
y tengo que ser muy sincero diciéndoles
no me arrepiento de un solo día
no me arrepiento de que me hayan dicho
que me volví loco no me arrepiento haber
tenido que
y alejarme un poco de mi familia al
principio
de haber tenido el dolor de
no sé mi hermana a quien adoro qué
casi dejara hablarme por diez años
porque era el raro
porque había dejado de ser el hermano
que ella quería
porque no era el hijo que mis papás
querían tal vez
me vuelvo un poco y cuento que después
de esta experiencia de la calle y
haberle dicho adiós que yo quería
dedicar mi vida a servir a los demás
no tuve mejor idea que venir el 24 de
diciembre y decirle a mi papá papá por
si acaso yo no va a ser la persona que
esperas
yo no quiero ser la persona exitosa
yo quiero ser católico de verdad quiero
servir a los demás esas dos cosas
mamá me miraba como este man si
realmente lo que decían es verdad que
está mal
y yo viva para que se le salieron las
lágrimas pero fue muy valiente y me dijo
no te entiendo no estoy de acuerdo pero
todo apoyar
y termina el diálogo diciendo me ve y no
valdría la pena como que te fueras al
psiquiatra y te hace una conversa dita
con él
y me fui a donde el psiquiatra donde el
crimen tal vez varios lo conocen y hablé
un par de días con él y al final me dice
querés que tranquilice a tu papá y le
digo y luego si me harías un gran favor
y me dijo bueno dale el seguir
vuelvo de nuevo a mi en la experiencia
de mi vocación
y de verdad no me arrepiento
esta es la foto del día en que me ordene
hace 6 años estos son algunos de mis
amigos de colegio 2 de ellos hacen parte
de la comunidad en la cual yo estoy yo
no los convencí para estar metidos en
esto terminamos haciendo tests raros de
este colegio que hacemos esto
respecto a las dos certezas que tengo en
mi vida
la primera
yo no fui quien elegí a dios dios me
eligió a mí
y tener esa certeza interior es algo que
me da mucha seguridad en mi vida y una
convicción muy grande hacia donde tengo
que ir
y hoy les quiero decir a cada uno
tengan claro que todos tenemos una
vocación en la vida acá hablaron de
dones
pero incluso yo iría un poco más al
fondo
estamos acá para algo
y dios nos ha dado una vocación y cuando
uno encuentra ese llamado esa ocasión
está el primer pilar sobre el cual se
construye la felicidad
yo no soy ni amargado ni como algunos
alguno me han dicho algún día
desperdiciaste tu vida o qué te pasó y
que niña te terminó votando que te
fuiste de cura o como fracasaste
de verdad no soy un fracasado soy muy
feliz
y yo creo que soy muy feliz porque tengo
esta certeza de mi vocación
y por qué dedicado mi vida a servir a
los demás
y creo que le he sido fiel al señor no
por mis fuerzas sino porque él me ha
ayudado
a entregarme con amor
y acá hay algo que es lo que realmente
cambia la vocación no cambia lo que sí
cambia
es
cómo uno va amando como uno va sirviendo
y pongo un ejemplo muy cortico ustedes
que son madres aman a sus hijos
pero esa amor cambia mucho de cuando su
hijo es un niñito a cuando es un
adolescente y no necesitan tanto caso
cuando es un viejo
pero siempre son madres
y tienen que irse adaptando en la
capacidad de amar
algo similar me pasa a mí
no me soñé ser cura
no me soñé ser educador hoy en día soy
educador dirijo un colegio en bogotá no
me soñé tener hijos y tengo 371 hijos
más todos los demás
y termino con una pequeña anécdota
esta niña es 'la y al inah mi sobrina de
la que les hable
el año pasado fuimos a
a ver al papá francisco en la calle 26 y
esa es la foto de con ella ese día
y ya está muy impresionada y de verdad
yo yo la quise llevar y mi hermana se
animó a ir porque
porque recuerdo cuando el papa juan
pablo segundo vino a colombia y a mí eso
me tocó y tal vez fue la experiencia de
dios que yo tuve que me acordé y yo dije
yo quiero que ella pueda tener esa
experiencia mis otros dos sobrinos
dijeron y no quisieron ir
y
y al final está dichosa y me dice tío
éste es tan chévere como esas misiones a
las que tú vas yo puedo ir contigo a
misiones y dije sí claro es un muy
chévere y la semana santa pasada ya
estuvo conmigo de misiones fue mi
hermana y mis dos sobrinas todavía
y hace dos domingos estaba con ella y le
digo hoy al y entonces tú quieres la
princesa guerrera dice
yo no soy princesa ya no soy princesa
bueno pero entonces de guerrera y me
dice ya no soy guerrera
ahora soy misionera
esto es lo que dice jesús
yo los elegí a ustedes y los destine
para que vayan y den fruto y su fruto
sea duradero muchas gracias
[Aplausos]